ok this is a pepper panic saga level 4
44 walkthrough tutorial video some
members and our facebook group we're
asking about their having trouble with
it so and go ahead and try to beat the
level explain why I made the decisions I
made um I just loaded the game up and I
actually got a nice in the first matches
there so that's cool if you're really
frustrated this level you can probably
use your quit button up here and cycle
through a few times until you get that
set up or something similar to it I
didn't do that here but it just it just
came out and if you like I had a yellow
one set up here too so if you really
having a hard time with this upper you
might want to do that it'll cut down on
the amount of you know moves to need to
get the last one of course when I make
my red one it's going to mess up yelling
but um you know who have to set that up
anyways there's only four colors on here
so it's not really that bad at least in
my opinion to set up two matches that
you need but what can be kind of bad is
the the cat will take things away when
right when you're in the middle of a
setup so you just want to be kind of
conscious of where he's at what he's
doing and you always have to you know he
can't make the elves without gaps or
pairs of you know light colored pepper
so that's what you want to look for see
where you have those and see what how
you can bring the extra peppers you need
together so here we have lots of pairs
but we don't have them in the right
places so what I'm going to do and what
is usually a good idea to do whenever
you
and you don't have exactly what you want
available you just want to drop things
down and see where they fall into place
and go from there if there was a
vertical match underneath this one I
might try for that but there's not so
I'm just going to start on this side and
sort of slide things down a little bit
he's down here so he's going to wipe out
the ones that are grown these are going
to stay there so I'm going to try to
work up here because that's where he's
not alright so here we have like part of
it but as you see things move around a
lot so we can get a yellow in here we
have it set up and this quick look below
shows us that he can't easily drop on
down there so I'm going to move that
women over it's kind of the same thing
here
this isn't going to help all that much
but I'm gonna go ahead and make the five
pepper what match to knock him out for
one move and see how things fall into
place and it didn't wasn't really that
favorable but you don't know until you
try so
so same thing here we have all that one
we can't get those down so we're going
to move that one over
see what we come up with
alright so we got one in the drop and
then we got the cycle in the drive so
that's nice and that's exactly why you
do that when you don't have anything
then you can set up when things are
dropping and there's only four colors on
the board it's very likely that you
could get the matching now the green I
think might be a little bit harder
because if you look around there's not
as many green peppers on the board and a
bunch of the ones that are on there now
are going to be swiped out of the way by
him so we're just going to let that
happen there's no way that he can really
save them and I'm just going to try to
create some action like so and see where
things end up
so just sort of weight in the past three
or so I'm just going to make another
magic let him go his way now right now
some now I wanted to try to set this up
so the Peregrine is here I'm going to
Peregrine I can make here going to drop
this a little bit lower first and now I
have a whole bunch of the matches ID
that I don't have it in the right place
I'm going to raise that one not and i'm
going to try to get another dreaming
down here i had these blue said this way
and when you're doing that always check
to see where things falling above
because like here now we have it on both
sides and you know we have a tea that
you don't really make it out so we have
green ones that we could drop down in
this world where we don't on that side
I'm go ahead and try to do that and this
is a little bit tricky because of this
screen pepper this is the only one to
drop down but if we do to make a match
so I don't want to deal with that is I'm
going to match the three on top get that
one out of the way so that won't make a
match here and then I'm going to move
the blue / and that's going to set it up
it's just a matter if it's going to stay
there or not so let's see what happens
and it did so that's all you got to do
and if you're looking at you're saying
all I never get lucky like that they
never happened in the Cascades that's
the case then you're probably not moving
things around as much as you should be
whether or not already set up for me
it's most satisfying to be able to move
them in place but at the same time with
the look with the cat there he's going
to move them out of your way if you have
any kind of growth on so you really
don't want to spend a whole lot of moves
trying to set one up unless you're sure
you're going to be able to get it so if
it's not there any money and you want to
try I would just makes make matches
below and then just check the board
every time and then once once you have
it where you can set it up set it up
like I did agreement all right any
questions leave a comment like the video
if you found it helpful and we'll be
making more healthy videos soon thanks